so
you're absolutely right tomorrow is a
very big day and the
the point i would make to everybody
wondering what to to do is if uh you
want to
help with your family budgets and you
want to uh make sure that you've got
more at the end of the month then make
sure that you vote uh conservative
because when you look at the uh the
the council taxes the efficiency of
conservative councillors versus uh
labour councillors uh it's it's labor
councils that go bankrupt it's
conservative councils that have a better
value for money conservative councils
have the lowest council taxes uh in the
country so bins are collected potholes
filled in better value for money
my second question to you do you agree
with your cabinet minister george eustis
that people should buy value ranges in
supermarkets to cut costs isn't that
advice patronizing and doesn't it
illustrate the fact that your government
doesn't understand the challenges people
are facing people will surely be doing
this already what we want to do is help
people in any way that we can through
the
aftershocks of kobe what you've got is
inflationary
spikes mainly in energy but that's
knocking on into all sorts of other
costs for for people for families so
we're helping in the in the in the
immediate term 22 billion package 9.1
billion pounds going on on fuel alone uh
all sorts of measures that people may
know about cutting your council tax
giving you support for uh for uh cold
weather payments and so on um extra
money for councils but the most
important thing
is to have a strong economy with high
wage high skilled jobs so here we are
at southampton airport where they have a
great plan to expand the number of jobs
that they they currently have
offer more services
but also
take steps to protect the environment at
the same time plus they've got a a free
port coming in uh of the site for uh the
um uh the
southampton
freeport will be partly based here and
uh that will again and that's something
we're able to do because of because of
brexit that will drive
more jobs as well so
the best future for the country is get
through the
the tough patch that we have now support
people in any way that we can but
remember this is uh
as we're now seeing a lot of employment
and people in high-wage high-skill jobs
that's a much better position to be in
than we were in the 1980s or 1990s so
the boss bp says the windfall tax
wouldn't dissuade them from investing in
the uk so doesn't that blow a hole in
your main claim about windfall taxes
will you not now consider it
they don't want a windfall tax and
there's a good reason for that and that
is because it would uh stop
investment in
new technology and in
new green uh power that we need the
problem we've got is that uh we this is
an incredible country incredible economy
fifth biggest in the world but we're
mainlining
energy
from france it's insane we haven't
invested enough in our own domestic
energy and we need these big energy
companies to step up to the plate and
put their money into uh sustainable
solutions of more green energy to help
keep costs down now that is a much much
better solution than clobbering them
and dissuading them stopping them uh
from making that investment we need
those companies to be investing now in
the in the power supply
is going to keep cost down
why is the rwanda refugee policy delayed
your own spokesperson has said there are
legal challenges with the policy it's
not viable is it there are bound to be
legal challenges but this is something
that uh we agreed the the
the migration and economic partnership
is something that we agreed uh with
rwanda it's a it's a great deal between
uh two countries to each helping the
other and yes of course there are going
to be
legal eagles
liberal lawyers who will try to make
this difficult of course we always knew
this was going to happen but is a very
very sensible thing if people are coming
across the channel illegally
and if they are their lives are being
put at risk by ruthless and unscrupulous
uh gangsters which is what is happening
at the moment you need a solution and
you need something that is going to say
to those people to those gangsters i'm
sorry
but you can't tell your customers you
can't tell these poor people that
they're just going to come to the uk and
they're going to be lost in the system
because we're going to find a way of
making sure that they go immediately to
rwanda and i think that's a humane
compassionate and sensible thing to do
i'm not going to pretend to you that is
going to be without legal challenges i
think i said that
when i announced it but we will get it
done